We already showed that
the torque about a point
can also be thought
of as a decomposition.
We take the vector from the
point P to the center of mass
and apply all the forces
acting on the particle
at the center of mass.
And we can calculate the
torque about the center
of mass due to the
action of some forces
where we're having forces
acting about the center of mass.
Now if we choose the point P
to equal the center of mass,
then we know that the
vector r center of mass
to the center of mass is 0.
So the torque about
the center of mass
is just equal to the
forces about that point.
We know that torque
is always just Lcm/dt.
Now, again, how could we
justify that statement
that because we're
only calculating
the torque about
the center of mass,
it's only the rotational angular
momentum about the center
of mass that's changing.
We saw before that if
we thought of Lp, again,
as a translational and a
rotational angular momentum--
I'm sorry, rotational
angular momentum, omega--
and the point p was equal
to the center of mass,
then this first
piece would be 0.
And L about p is only
Icm omega and dLp/dt
is equal to Icm alpha
for a fixed axis.
And that's exactly
equal to dLcm/dt.
And so the point
here is that when
we're applying problems
involving rotation
and translation, we can
just analyze the torque
about the center of
mass and only consider
how the angular momentum about
the center of mass is changing.
And then for the
center of mass motion--
so this gives us our
rotational dynamics.
And for our linear
dynamics, we will still
apply F equals the
total mass times Acm.
So that's our linear dynamics.
And this is our
overall decomposition
of rotational motion.
To analyze it, we study
the rotational dynamics
and the linear dynamics.